كيف ستتغير السياسه الخارجيه لتركيا في
حال فوز كليتشار اوغلو بالرئاسه ملفات مثل
العلاقات مع مصر وسوريا والتواجد العسكري
في ليبيا ستكون على راس قائمه التغيير
اتخذ موقفا واضحا برفض سياسه اردوغان واكد
انها تكلف تركيا الكثير من الخسائر
وتعزلها وتؤثر سلبا على مصالحها فبالنسبه
لمصر ومنذ عام 2013 رفض كلتشتار اوغلو
تعامل اردوغان مع العلاقات مع مصر على
انها علاقات مع تنظيم الاخوان ووصفهم
وقتها بانهم تنظيم ارهابي بالنسبه لليبيا
تساءل كلتشدار اوغلو عن اسباب ارسال الجيش
التركي الى الصحراء هناك وما هي مصلحه
البلاد من هذه الخطوه وتعهد باعادتهم في
حال فوزه بالانتخابات اما في الملف السوري
تبدو رؤيه كيليتشار اوغلو واضحه عبر عنها
مرارا مؤكدا ان اولى خطواته ستكون العمل
على اعاده العلاقات بين اليدين وايضا
اعاده اللاجئين خلال عامين عبر التنسيق مع
دمشق والاتحاد الاوروبي والامم المتحده
لتامين حياه كريمه لهم المرشح المعارض
يتبنى موقفا مؤيدا للمفاوضات والحوار بين
اذربيجان وارمينيا بدلا من ارسال الدعم
العسكري لباكو ضد يرافان هنا لابد من طرح
مساله مهمه جدا في الداخل التركي وهي
الاعتراف بمجازر الارمن هو امر يتفق فيه
كلتش دار اوغلو مع اردوغان ويرفض الاعتراف
والتدخل الغربي في هذه القضيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات